- Mein Name ist Matthias Wentland.
Ich bin Geschäftsführer im
Pflegeteam Wentland.
- Mein Name ist Patrycja Dalecka.
Ich bin im zweiten Ausbildungsjahr
als Altenpflegerin.
Seit zwei Jahren bin ich
im ambulanten Pflegedienst.
- Mein Name ist Rachid Afarsiou.
Ich bin Krankenpfleger,
arbeite für einen ambulanten Pflegedienst,
der circa 105 Patienten versorgt aktuell.
Genau, ich bin mit dem Auto
unterwegs zu den Patienten,
wo ich zu denen nach Hause fahre
und die dort versorge vor Ort.
- In der mobilen Pflege
fahren die Krankenpfleger zu
den Patienten nach Hause.
Ein wichtiger Aufgabenbereich:
die Grundpflege.
Hier geht es um die
Grundversorgung des Patienten:
Der Krankenpfleger wäscht und pflegt ihn.
Er muss viel mit dem Patienten sprechen.
Außerdem gibt es weitere
wichtige Aufgaben,
wie den Blutzucker zu messen ...
oder Verbände zu wechseln.
Alle Tätigkeiten, die man bei
jedem Patienten erledigt hat,
müssen dokumentiert werden.
Auch ein Gespräch mit den
Angehörigen kann dazugehören.
Mehr über den Beruf des Krankenpflegers
erfahrt ihr im nächsten Teil.